Hello everybody!
Hello!
Too many loops, too many loops that we DC'd a little bit,
but now we're here.
Hello!
The Duchess has returned to Dokeland.
It has been a while.
It has been a couple of months since we last checked out
Dokeland.
Um, I have been very busy.
Uh, so let's see what you guys have been up to.
For those who don't know what Dokeland is, it is the Doke
SMP.
Uh, So it's our very own Minecraft server for all the
dragoons, all the member goons.
So you can be, if you want to join the member, the dragoon
Minecraft server, you just got to be a member.
And a lot of dragoons hang out there.
And there is a Discord dedicated to it.
To the Doki SMP server.
Yeah, I know Chad is dead.
I just forgot to add you guys here.
There you guys go.
Yay.
Yes.
Pixel Doki.
I forgot.
I forgot this Doki's name.
There's too many dokees.
I'm losing track of all the dokees in the dokeverse.
I know someone made a website to help me keep track of all
the dokees.
I don't remember this dokees name.
Oh, is this, was this pixel bird?
Was this pixel bird or 8-bit dokee?
I don't know.
King, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you for the skater boy fun.
is at uh 792k views let's go skater boy cover thank you for
the super chat oh my god can't believe it's like less than a
month we're already are close to like 800k thank you
everybody thank you guys i really appreciate for all the
support yes the second stream of the day i wanted to yeah
like my little shimmy whoa oh my god like how the minecraft
axe actually fits for what actually fits the vibe for once
whoa my little my little shimmy
sorry uh i had to loop all that uh there was a lot of loops
because i was disassociating uh i already forgot like all
the stuff i can this uh oh wait it's not angry why did i
have this as angry wow oh my god my all my this is all wrong
all right all right all right dad is still here okay like
all of it names are not correct i was just like wait a
minute oh that's not angry this does not look like anger all
right all right don't keep it okay all right that's quick
thank you thank you for giving for reminding me about the
official name all right let's check it out it has been a
while since we looked at the at uh at the dokey smp so let's
see what you guys have been up to lately um oh yeah let me
do the bgm real quick uh what bgm do i want to play for you
to uh let's do this the classic
here we go i'm gonna pit this let me see if i tell tab this
oh hey no i can't all right i gotta do this windowed.
I got windowed my Minecraft real quick, guys.
Oh, why is there music in my Minecraft?
What the fuck?
We all know we use our own music for Minecraft.
This is that it's been so long.
It really has been way too long.
I'm just like, what the fuck?
Where the fuck?
I don't even remember.
Oh, here we go.
Why is that 240?
It should be at 500.
Oh, wait, not like that, though.
Give me a sec.
500.
There we go.
If I have problems now, if I tap out, no, I don't.
Yay!
I fixed it.
Well, you guys don't see it yet, but let me turn down the
audio.
Get that shit out.
out of here.
It's been so a lot.
Oh, wait.
Am I broken?
Okay, I was gonna say, am I broken?
Alright, there we go.
Alright, Doki SMP.
Get me in.
Bada-dada-dada.
Alright.
Hello, admin.
Let there be light.
Hello, fellow admin.
Give me the tour.
Show me what I missed out.
There we go.
What have I missed out?
Hello, admin.
Let there be sun, too.
Fuck the rain.
Wait, is it uncapped FPS?
I don't even remember.
No, it's 120.
God, that scared me there.
Clear it.
The Lord has spoken.
Let there be...
Oh, shit.
Okay.
what is new here whoa what is this oh my god that's cool oh
my god he's the special one he's our special little guy
that's right congrats on oh my god wait since you're called
iboos now what are they called i goons draboos Oh my god,
what's this?
Oh my god, this was the Phantom Thief concert!
That's the Phantom Thief concert stage!
Oh, that's cute.
Draboos or Igoons?
Concert, yeah, it's the Phantom Thief stuff.
Oh my god, that's right.
Eyes-
Yes!
Open the server!
admin open the server
I demand a coliseum match
I demand a show I want a show demand a sacrifice get in here
everyone entertain me oh shit hey what are you doing over
here oh cool wait that's new i didn't know look there's like
little landmark stuff now underneath that's new yeah here we
go so how does this work is this wait is this dodgeball
everyone pick a late pick a state oh wait that's not
everyone pick a side I don't know how this works that's
right go to your team is this leaf oh is this dodgeball
that's right
pick your side is dodgeball equip them now old versus new
blood who will win the new goons are the old goons what
items do we need I don't fucking know I didn't build this I
just sit on the throne and be entertained they're like what
It was too easy.
I don't know.
I'm just here to be entertained.
What do you mean?
I don't...
Oh, yeah.
The Timmy's versus the Yimmy's.
Yeah, he should have been...
No, it's the old...
The new blood and the old blood.
Oh, what's this?
Are you not entertained?
I demand my show.
How does this start?
That's right.
You can't hit me.
I'm invincible.
I love rule overall.
Horn, horn, horn, horn.
That's right.
Who is that guy?
Yeah, stupid.
Who's throwing that?
Who was it?
Who threw that?
Yeah?
That's fucking right.
Oh shit, what the fuck?
That's right, you can't hurt me.
I have the stick.
I have the dokey bong stick.
Alright, how are we starting this?
Alright.
We are all ready to start.
I want to know.
Alright, everybody.
It was that one.
Alright.
Alright, place your bets, guys.
Let's put a poll out.
Let me pull a poll out.
Who will win?
Old goons.
New goons.
Let's have a poll.
Alright, I don't know how to start this.
I don't have a file.
Wait, I do know how the fireworks.
Alright, the moment, the moment I send this firework out.
Oh my gosh, so many maps.
I don't know which one's the stupid one that I don't need.
Give me a sec.
I have two.
Okay, this one for sure.
Alright, the moment I...
Okay, the moment I send out this firework, you All right.
Are we all good?
All right.
Artokilat is run by old people.
Everyone arm themselves.
You have your weapons.
All right.
Here we go.
Go.
bump bump but oh fight fight wait i don't even know who's
yellow and who's red who's purple i they're on each other's
sides which was yellow and which was purple i've already
lost track i've already wait they're flying that's illegal
well guys i don't even know who won i'm a small oversight
it's a free-for-all all right the winner the win i like how
they're flying out of the pits now they're like oh don't
care who's the last one standing wait him who's this guy
azzy that's right in the end I'm the winner that's right the
polls were rigged in the end I claimed my $50,000 bet I'm
the winner Doki wins
I don't even know.
I think we like play.
I like how the naked good is just standing there watching
the horse Guys, I don't think we played it correctly guys.
I whoa where am I Player one player two Player three How
does all of this work?
I like how they're still fighting.
I'm just exploring now.
I'm just I'm just exploring this.
How does this all work?
Was there supposed to be a plug-in?
Oh, here.
We should make a plug-in for this to make this actually
work.
Write this down, admin.
Write this down.
As he is old goon, old goon wins.
Yeah, I want to make this actually work for people, for my
entertainment.
Because I love the...
Oh my god, I keep getting stuck.
I keep getting stuck.
Because I love the stage.
I lost my Electra.
Too bad you should have had...
You should have picked up insurance.
Indokilan.
You didn't pay for insurance.
Alright!
Congratulations, old goons.
Congratulations.
The old goon won.
Alright.
To reward you.
To reward Ozzy for winning.
For winning the battle.
Royale.
Why am I?
Wait.
I'm dead right now.
Why am I not moving?
Okay, there we go.
I was going to say.
Why am I not moving?
What happened?
All right.
Admin.
Take me to my house.
Because I forgot how to TP there.
Admin.
Take me to my house.
Because I forgot how to TP.
TP.
Wait, you're not admin.
To reward Azzi for a job well done.
Also, let there be light.
Put him in...
Oh, hey, how did he...
Put him in the cage.
Put him in the...
Put him in there.
that's right you think you're better than the rest of the
dragoons you think you're better than the rest of us that's
right all dragoons are created equally
yeah that's the right person you got it the right person all
dragoons are created equally All dragoons are winners.
How dare you think you're better than the rest of us?
Into the cage you go.
I'm even scared.
But some are more equal than others.
That's right.
All right.
Adam, take me to a new place.
Take me to the...
new place that's been built what the fuck can i have food
please no
starve until you learn your lesson
all right what's this oh my god wait is that is this germany
again dude Wait, this is new.
Is this the White House?
Where is this?
Welcome to the Longoon Library.
Here all written works on the server as long as it's our
meticulous archive and safely stored.
We can hold up to 2,000 is what I would say.
We had any books to shelve.
We just opened after all so nobody's reading anything.
Feel free to wander around.
Oh, cool.
Wait, there's an actual library.
Ozzy.
you what are you directory book lending process oh my god we
have we have notebooks
wrong answer but not because of the gay part just covering
my vases i want to get canceled now not the answer I was
expecting.
It's not the answer I was expecting.
How come no one wrote anything?
Is it because no one can't read a dokeelon?
Coffee station.
To make sure.
Guys!
Where are my doctor goons?
My writer goons?
goons.
My literate goons.
Okay, we'd like to extend to all map artists displayed
there.
Oh, cool.
In the reading room.
Oh, that's cool.
Oh, everyone is stuck in the arena?
Well, you know there's one way to get out of the arena.
There's only one way to get out of the arena.
the only place to read is the fan fiction of course it is i
sent them all to the oh there's a chicken here i sent them
all to the coliseum dear toky you killed them no witnesses
no one shall write if all the people that were participating
are dead they'll never have to there's never going to be any
history about it there's actually no books there's actually
no books i haven't found a single book it's cool though
wait there's a where's the fanfic place i didn't see it
no one can archive history if all of them are dead can't
write about my crimes because i didn't commit any There's a
whole fanfic library and the old server is pretty awesome.
They even super chat next to you.
They get they.
Oh, we still have the old server, right?
Yeah.
We still have the old server.
Alright.
Admin, take me to a new place.
Oh.
Oh my god.
The fanfic in the shop.
Oh, we are.
Dad one, dad two.
Wait, that's cute.
That's cute.
I like that.
Where is my item area?
Oh, I have too many things in my storage.
I already got rid of this.
All right.
Read the rules first.
Only save for work for now.
After, make sure you give the original.
Have fun writing.
write your own right right here okay and then also fanfics
with authors horror oh my god completed a challenge serious
dedication hey whose book is this what horror what happened
what was in my uh dim florence and lights flickered in the
dingy hallways I will once A beloved pizza restaurant The
Wallace Day What happened?
Lacked out a little bit What happened, guys?
What?
Joki, remind me why we are vlogging This whole thing instead
of streaming Actually, having chat here Would make it way
less scary The yellow feather women's side Knowing this was
Knowing this neither the first Or the last time she would be
explaining this Without any cause That's how we make it
authentic stuff.
I'm kind of regretting it now.
This is a bit too much, said the wispy green maid, heel to
toe.
Oh my god.
Wait, who wrote this?
Oh my god, there's more?
Why do I have 16 copies of this?
Wait, what do I do?
I have too many copies?
Oh, by aura, copy of...
There's 16 of them.
How do I have 16 copies?
Alright.
How do I...
Phantom Thief By written by Oh my gosh Once there was a cute
pair named Phantom Thief She or they anyway Be so cute that
everyone died Make it be full of happiness despite the death
The end Oh wait I have extra copies now Oh that's why That's
why I see now Wait let me I had a great experience writing
the books I had a great desire for more of this literature
Wait, how do I write?
I don't remember how to write.
In Minecraft, guys.
In Minecraft.
Wait, I can write this.
Once upon a time, there was a ghost and a bird.
They held hands without...
Protection.
And then they died.
Save handholding, please.
Alright.
There you go.
I've added to the collection.
Literally the new Romeo.
and Juliet.
Safe protection.
That's safe for work.
That's literally safe for work.
Wait, is this the update with different variation of pets?
Or is that a feature update?
This is my Shakespeare.
I know Minecraft has updated a lot.
Bada, bada, bada, bada.
Now that's the real treasure thing.
Oh, that's Umamusume.
I know her.
Oh, this is Umamusume.
Wait, is this like parkour?
What's this for?
We should have a parkour tower.
Guys, remember?
Guys, we should have a parkour tower.
Guys, guys, dragons, dragons.
I want that to be the next project.
And then, whatever you guys get together, and build a
parkour tower like a giant parkour tower um the next time
the next month when i come visit i'll do the child i'll do
the parkour challenge i want to be like a super tall like a
parkour tower yeah did you learn nothing from last time i
silly dragons oh what the fuck is this i never learned
make a parkour tower i'll go i'll go play i'll go try it out
next stream oh that is so cool wait that's sick no no it's
like uh this is the most players and i'm glad i'm gonna a
lot of people are coming back and the server yeah yeah i
want to add more stuff to the server i haven't been like on
top of it lately just because i've been busy with everything
else but i want to get back into Yeah, I wonder what the
winner of the parkour tournament will win, Lolly.
Thank you, Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
This is a really cool-ass airship.
But yeah.
But yeah, that would be a cool project.
A little parkour tower that we called.
What the fuck?
What is he this guy doing?
What was he doing?
Oh, what is this?
The above ahead of not is not done because Orca's claim.
So yeah, work in progress.
What's this?
Oh, what is this?
Holy shit, what the fuck is this?
I can't tell what this is exactly, but it looks cool.
Oh, there's an hour!
I mean, that's an hour, though, isn't it?
Is that not an hour?
What am I...
It's pretty.
Um, um, um, I love how there's like layers to it too.
Like a giant tower over here.
It's really pretty.
I like that.
Oh my god, you got it.
Dragoons are so...
Oh, there's the orca.
I was like, where the fuck is this orca you're talking
about?
I was like, I am pretty sure that's an owl.
I was like, where the fuck is this orca?
And I was like, oh, there it is.
There's the orca.
yeah that's it i was just like damn i was like am i stupid
where the fuck is this orca yeah i was like oh there's the
orca there's oh my god by the way um i was gonna talk about
it tomorrow but my resident evil vibe the last stream got
age restricted and i thought that was so fucking funny.
I was like, how the fuck did Resident, I guess from the
killing and stuff?
Like, but the, yeah, it got age-restricted.
It was too scary, too scary for the YouTubes.
But also I thought it was really funny because I was
thinking about, like, I saw an article about how Japanese
players are really mad about the censorship for Resident
Evil.
Because I don't know if you guys know this, but Resident
Evil censorship is, like, in Japan, is really, really bad,
because, like, they're, because they put, like, black bars.
Not those type of black bars, but...
But if it's too gory, if it's too gory, if there's too much
blood and decapitation, they actually, like, put a giant
black box around it.
So, wait, let me show you guys.
There's a screenshot of it.
Let me show you guys real quick.
I thought it was really funny, because, like, So apparently
because this Resident Evil, there's a lot of, uh, there's a
lot of gore and stuff.
Like the majority of game is just black sensor bars and
like, and people were complaining super hard because they're
like, like it was, you know, it was ruining the, like the
Japanese players were complaining super hard because it was
ruining the immersion.
And then I was like, how bad can it be?
And I saw the picture and I was like, oh, that's, that's
pretty bad.
This is how bad the censorship is if you play the Japanese
version.
I was just like, what the?
Like, how do you see anything?
How do you see?
That's really bad.
So that's why there's like a lot of complaints about it in
Japan.
Because like, you know, the Japanese people on Twitter are
seeing the NA version.
And then they're like, what the fuck?
What?
They're just like, what the fuck?
Guys, does my game look like this?
Like, it's just a black-ass rectangle.
Is it...
No, it's not edited.
That's actually how it looks.
My god.
It's not even edited.
That's actually how the censorship looks like in Japan.
Which I thought was really fucking funny.
Wait, how did he get out?
Fuck
his army!
That's right.
Run!
It's like a fucking fly swatter.
You were supposed to be in jail.
Okay, please.
All right, Iver is insane.
All right, Adam, take me to a new... Oh, wait, what's this?
Oh, that's cool.
Is that... Is this yours?
Wait, let me show you.
check, or are you just a home invader?
Are you taking his credit?
Alright, do you own this?
Oh, that's not your house!
You took credit!
Bad!
Oh.
Wait, what?
Wait, what's the point?
I don't understand.
Why can't I hit anyone?
Admin, give me the power to kill.
Good one, and run, Dragloon.
Figuring it out.
That's right.
Give me the power.
What's the point of being a god?
If I can't exercise my rights.
This is my right.
That's right.
Admin.
Don't just slash kill him.
I want to be able to do it with my own hands.
Just you.
No.
I want to do it with my own hands.
I'm here to talk to you.
to you about your car's extended warranty.
Wait, what the fuck?
What happened?
What did I do?
You feel bad about that but not murder?
the shipyard with the dokey navy that's right oh my god in
the fake train area the fake train tunnel
that's so sick this build must have taken so a lie
wait there's a resource pack what oh that's cool oh my god
it got wait they're building another one Oh my god, they're
building another one.
Guys, we need a Gundam in our server.
Like, we need a Joki Gundam.
Just like in Japan.
Where am I now?
What is this place?
Oh, it's an indoor.
Oh, I thought that we were in a cave.
But it's like a cave civilization.
You broke my...
Oh, I don't know what you're talking about.
I didn't break anything.
Casey, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
What are you talking about?
Nothing was broken in Dokilan.
It must have been the wind.
Public infrared rare system.
Improvements to mod grinder.
Entertainment houses.
Oh, wait, there's a casino?
Where's the casino?
Where's the entertainment?
More on front.
Clay drying area.
Guys, I need to go.
I learned how to play poker this morning.
I...
Where are you going to take this in court?
The legal system is owned by me.
How are you going to sue me?
You know who your judge is?
Me!
You know who the jury is?
Good luck in suing me in Dokilan.
I control the judicial system.
Wait, where's the...
I must find the casino.
I learned how to play poker.
We will find a way.
It's not corruption.
It's how it's always been.
How is it corruption if it's always like that?
Oh, don't.
Down.
Where the fuck is the casino?
I must scamba.
Oh my god, I don't know where the casino is Maybe it's
downstairs
Downstairs for our crimes
Where's the casino?
That's all I want Such an adorable tyrant, oh she is Thank
you, the super chat, thank you It says there's a casino
here.
Oh, it's the city of Amber
Po- Stokey bird statue in town square
I went to the door.
I must gamba.
This is my blood.
It's my jeans.
Where is it?
Oh, is it here?
My dad's actually really, really good at poker.
this i don't know if there's it's still around but on qq
they had this like little they had this card game site uh
where they were like like blue like there was like pixel
avatars and stuff too for it um and there's like added i
don't remember if people know about this like it's from qq
um and they had like this gambling website i'm not gambling
website sorry poker website uh or app where people would
play poker and stuff online um and my dad was like oh is
this the casino that's No, don't take me to the tavern.
I want the tavern.
I don't know if people know the app, but I don't know the
name of it.
I just know it's like ran by QQ.
And the more points you win, the more you can buy like
customization for your avatar.
Or like those like highlight like highlight intros and stuff
or like finishers intros and stuff that you can buy when you
win.
And, um, and he was also really, he was really good at
counting cards.
I mean, he still is, I assume.
Like, he would, he would count cards and stuff.
I'm just, like, thinking, like, people are like, oh, you're
not, that's legal to count cards.
And I'm like, then how, it's, it's literally, like, how you
can win, though.
Like, I still don't know where the casino is.
I've been in the city for 20 years.
Yeah, it is bannable.
But I don't know how do you even get caught, though, for
counting cards?
Why is counting cards, like, frown upon?
Because, like, isn't that just another skill to win?
Yeah, I was gonna say.
Isn't it just another, like, skill-wise to, like, win?
Win in poker?
Oh, because casino loses money.
Yeah, because you're not chump.
All right.
Does anyone know where the casino is?
Anyone?
Anyone here know where the casino is?
Wait, all right.
Azzi.
Have you learned your lesson?
And what have you learned?
All right.
Over here.
Who said that?
Is there like some guy, one guy, trying to one guy me?
And be like, it's over here.
And he's not even here with us.
Who knows where the casino is?
Over here.
I know.
I don't see you guys in here.
Okay.
Here.
You know where it is, right?
Who knows where it is?
Repeat after me, Ozzy.
Doki Duchess Doki Bird is just and kind and she knows what's
right for all right guys I give up I don't think I can find
the casino okay now that's it don't let him have the items
make them all their items you know what delete his inventory
he will pull he will pull the trigger unless unless you say
nothing I
will Imagine starting all the way from zero.
I'm not glad my stuff is no longer on the server.
That's right.
You know what?
Azzi, who is your friend on this server?
Yeah.
name one all right delete Betty's inventory too
we unless you apologize we will delete your friend's
inventory Tori.
See, I saw you.
That's right.
Punish all those who associate with Bosnia.
Bro did nothing.
That's right.
You didn't see me.
This is a hostage situation now.
This is a hostage situation.
Oh, I can do it.
Admin, take me to where Ozzy is.
Yeah, you're right, Bob.
Take you down with me.
That's right.
I want to look into his eyes.
Where is he?
Where the fuck?
This is the...
That's right.
Let me look into your eyes.
Oh.
How did he die?
How did he...
I didn't even do anything.
What happened to him?
He had a heart attack.
Alright.
Wait, he only had one item.
He had nothing.
This guy had nothing on him.
That's so sad.
Where does he live?
Show me his house.
Show me where he lives.
I would of course hit a lady.
Equal rights.
What?
I'm a lady.
Of course I can hit a lady.
Show me where he lives.
Alright.
L.
Actually, Adam is showing me.
What is wrong with you?
Apollon.
Repeat after me.
Have you learned your lesson?
Joki have skilled for less.
Stand your ground.
Have you learned your lesson?
Wait.
These items despawn.
That's funny.
Items despawn when you don't repeat after me.
Say this.
I, Azzi, humbly apologize for how foolish and stupid I've
been and I will never act out towards the queen the duchess
of Doki Lai alright that's all you have to say
that's all you have to say Azzi I found your house I found
your house that's all All you have to say.
All this because she won the arena.
Ozzy.
I found it all.
I'm tired.
That's it.
I'll do this by hand.
I'll even do this wait why I'll even do this by hand that's
how much I'll enjoy this that's the right
brick by brick you
know what put a border
That's right, guys.
All dragoons are created equally.
Alright.
Dragoons, help me finish this.
We'll work together.
Help me finish this, dragoons.
Go!
Finish the rest of this.
They finished the rest of this!
Go!
Oh, wait, they can't do it.
Oh, they can't.
They don't have the power.
Oh, shit.
Wait, actually, give it back, guys.
Give it back, guys.
Dragon should not have access to bedrock, everyone.
Oh, shit.
I forgot we didn't sleep, but it's okay.
We don't have to worry about that.
Alright, brick by brick.
Alright, guys, no, that's not bedrock, guys.
That doesn't work like that.
He's gonna be able to breach it.
Alright, there we go.
Guys, guys!
They're gonna be able to dig through that!
No, no, I just realized giving you guys bedrock was a bad
idea.
That was a bad idea.
We're gonna have a bedrock problem soon.
We're gonna...
I fucked up a little bit.
I started to destroy the economy, but that's okay.
All right, if anyone gets locked in, that's on you guys.
All right.
If any of you guys get locked in, that's on you guys.
That's your forever prison.
Guys, guys, he's gonna be able to dig through wool.
all right here you go hope we all learn our valuable lesson
today oh
shit wait what happened to my bedrock
guys no don't trick me with the regular cobblestones
yokey and he is at her very poor source site this is your
main king name a better do guys guys why are you building it
higher guys
okay it has to be like it has to be like framed too you know
oh you're not putting secret openings oh you're not fooling
me just because it looks the same color I can tell
you're not fooling me you're not creating secret entrances
for this person
you're not No secret entrances.
Your house is gone, gone.
The secret tunnel.
Don't think you can hide this from me.
I can tell.
It has to be bedrock only so they can't dig through.
That's right.
You can't fool me.
that's where i see through it all oh you thought just
because the colors are the same that i won't see it okay
that one had a fucking tree like there we go there we go
oh my god i almost missed that
almost missed that one too
I am very determined.
Oh, shit.
I forgot underground.
Okay, now that's too much.
I give up.
I forgot the underground part.
This is a training exercise.
Now that they mentioned the underground, I was like, that's
too much work.
I'm done here.
I'm...
They want...
I can't...
I can't do the...
The border and underground at the same time.
They would.
At least.
No, I'm fine.
All right, take.
I can't even see a game box.
All right, take me to the new area.
Take me to the new area.
I'm very determined.
I give up.
Oh, hey.
Oh, that's cute.
Oh.
That's me.
Oh, that's cool.
It's a walleye.
That's cool.
But yeah, you guys want to join the server, by the way.
It's pinned in my chat.
Oh, my name is Doakitty.
It's pinned on my chat on how to join the server.
It is reserved for members only.
But yeah, I'm hoping to do an update on the server soon.
I really want to see, yeah.
But one of the things I really want to do is see is actually
the parkour tower.
by Ozzy?
No, I was gonna do something.
I won't vandalize it.
See, I'm a good person.
I'm a good
What's this?
Doki.
Oh my God.
This was Doki Land.
This was I very much like payment.
This was your 12th notice pay rate.
The rent, where is it?
It was tax fraud.
The two poor yet not allowed to pay rent, weird.
Don't ask me how I lied.
Help me kill him.
I am you from the future.
Pay rent.
Need that rent.
Might let another silent in.
I'm broke.
Might have to cut the tree down.
Last time I even rent my tree out.
All squat and no rent makes L a doll silent.
Whoever reads this is very short and needs to pay.
below maybe pay red cactus was right about to free load I
also wrote a message last chance where's the money hey
croaky reds too croaky red is too red we don't even have
easy why live here silent croaky red is to pay or i double
it pretty please please might evict this crowd loud sound
guy should live here instead um don't keep it who's set,
taking one of your eggs.
Do you even, do you want to play Marvel Rivals?
Crooky, why was this something I said?
Stop avoiding my cause.
Right now.
Oh my god, how bad did it get?
Just this word sound guy i don't know what to do about him
he won't pay next thing thank you for the super chat thank
you thank you thank you so much and then do you want to play
marvel rivals i i think they want their rent to be paid guys
i think the landlord experience poor guy that's all he
wanted He just wanted...
Next thing, again, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh my god.
It's like enemies to lovers.
What else is here?
Welcome to the facility.
What the fuck is this?
Welcome to facility.
It's like an item sorter.
It does stuff.
Do not ask about our labor conditions.
Um...
What?
How do I even use this?
Okay, bird, whose silent verse stream went?
These guys, you guys are funny.
What the fuck is this?
How do I even activate it?
The torment nexus?
The fuck is that?
Do not turn into bedrock.
How does this work?
does anyone know how this works it just works
how do you do anything on here it's an item sorter but like
how does this work
a fucking course not look at it i don't think they wait i
don't think they even know how it works i i i'm so confused
like holy shit did they made a fucking pc they made a gpu oh
my god but how do i sort the item where where is the sorter
part it's an item sorter but like i live here and i forgot
how it works
here.
Down where?
Down here?
Oh my god!
Main item input trash.
I don't know.
Shit's lonely out here.
I ran out of quartz.
Sup, sup.
It would explode.
Wait, where?
Put where?
Here?
Alright, I'm gonna put a diamond I did it did it work
because they gonna start sorting is it broken did we broke
it I just got here how did we break it wait wait it's
sorting it's gone it's sorting wait what does it look like
oh my god where's the diamond area okay I put it's diamond
where is it where's diamond nature and shit terracotta uh
stone and shit where the fuck is diamond oh okay there's
dies oh my god what the fuck there's
oh wait was the diamond named i just chucked a random
diamond oh okay wait i have something that's not named okay
i'll fix it don't worry
okay all right me and my evil lab building machine while
drunk and forgetting what they do in the morning be like
gordon thank you for the super chat thank you thank you all
right where's ores stone and shit cop oh there you go it's
not in here
i put my diamond in here or like that should be ores and
shit right
unless there's diamonds here
our diamond now did he just stole my diamond using when the
paramedic hit with you with the what the fuck which one's
the diamond oh is it going through the system right now wait
is it here no that's a diamond block
that's crazy that's so cool though I know this shit This
shit works like that Yeah I was gonna say It's like a fake
item Oh there it is Wait where is it going Wait it's
disappearing Where did it go?
Look It's gone Wait where did it go?
Whoops It's being moved Where did it get moved to it was
like
it was here though it's like a ghost but how is it being
processed where is it being processed to
I'm so confused
the hopper behind the bottom chest
why the fuck is it in the hopper and not the chest
Bless me I I gave up Admin Take me to a new place I've given
up I saw my diamond disappear in front of me I knew this was
a This was a con all along I fucking knew it.
I knew this item sort of was a scam.
Joki is listening.
Damn right.
There's more art.
Yeah, I was getting noticed.
There's a lot more art now in the art wall.
Oh, the little village.
We're a new art artwork each week.
Oh, that's cool.
They're passionate about art.
Let them draw.
I think I like this.
The croaky one is really good.
I like that.
Oh, it's like more map art here.
No other maps.
Minto size.
Okay.
What's this?
Scares, wares.
What's scary?
Slot.
Hag.
Smelting.
Oh!
Oh, that is so cool.
It's like the world map.
Well, not the world map, but like, oh my god, there's
croaky.
There's croaky over it.
Oh, it's like a...
Oh.
Oh, I love that.
Get it?
It's like hot slag, but fun.
Oh, is that slut?
No, that's slot.
Okay.
Each side, welcome to slot, tag, smelting.
Smell up to a hundred.
Oh, okay.
You're bored while waiting for your items.
Feel free to check out the flower park to your right.
Axelotos and frogs can be purchased in their respective
exhibits.
You can check out the perfect horse project up ahead.
Chakori, thank you for the attention.
a super they could thank you wait that's so cool flower park
oh named in honor of god oh not named of not named in honor
of all the flowers yeah oh that's pretty that's beautiful
that's actually really pretty where's the horse project
though there was apparently a secret horse project
Frog.
Price one slime ball per tadpole.
Oh, look at all these frogs.
There's like a frog adoption center.
Where's the Axelado adoption center?
That's cute.
A little adoption center for frogs.
Leave that horse alone.
I don't have to do anything bad to it yet.
Where's the Axelado?
Axelotto Adoption Center.
Did they take all the axelotos?
Oh, there's the little moosh room.
The free sniffer stuff.
Oh, these guys.
The sniffer.
Hello, these little guys.
They, like, give you flowers and stuff, right?
Meow.
Oh, I need to figure out where the horseies are.
They said the horsies are up ahead.
What does he mean by that?
Holy shit, sauce for smelting?
Oh my god, there's so many cool things.
You guys are so creative.
Dry wounds.
I always love seeing all the stuff you guys build.
All the funny shit you guys make.
Oh, I'm here.
Alright, where do we go?
Oh, welcome to...
Oh, perfect horse project.
The quest to breed a horse with max health, speed, and jump.
Use the tester.
Oh, this is the perfect horse project.
Oh.
Oh, that's crazy.
The ultimate umamusume.
Right here.
Horse stats.
Carl.
What's your...
What the fuck is that name?
What is that from?
What's the reference for that?
Min-maxing.
Yeah, they're min-maxing Umamusume right now.
Oh my god.
There's actually a timer too.
Like, ready, set, go!
And then you- Oh wait, you go from all the way there.
Min max speed.
Oh my god.
It actually says it.
Min max speed.
High speed and high jump.
Breeding pen.
Here's the breeding pen.
Oh, it was at the.
It was here.
Can you ever play Uma Musume with your life on the line?
Alright, what other new stuff is there, admin?
Whoa.
I spent the past three days on this.
The build is on the right.
Thanks, Azraf, for the help.
What is this?
Is it a spider?
Oh, it's map art.
Oh!
What art is it?
But which map is it?
Is it...
Is it the drive one?
Oh, it's the...
These two?
Oh, that's cool.
I was like, what the fuck?
Is this a spider?
Oh, I see it.
I see it.
Oh, that's sick.
So that's how map art works.
Oh, my God.
I can slowly...
I'm, like, seeing the picture.
Oh, my God.
I do not have render distance enough for it.
I'm seeing a picture being built before my eyes.
Yeah.
Oops.
There we go.
Oh, that's cool.
That's cool.
I didn't know that's how map art works.
Yeah.
You slowly back up.
And then you'll get beautiful artwork like this.
Or like this.
Awu.
It says awu, but what it is.
is this it's just someone died like did they blow it up all
right mine or admin what's this gang remember to write a
review gold shape our new advancement on aquarium technology
question how would affect the salmon economy what the fuck
would smash would fuck i'm very confused.
How?
An error occurred.
Wait, how how did he do this?
Wait, it's see-through.
Chat, is this real?
How did he do this?
Is this real?
Chat, is this real?
How did he make that work?
Oh my god, sorcery, puffer tree, grow, entree.
Oh my god.
Sorcery, bat him.
We would show you.
Burn him.
She's a witch.
A witch.
The other technologies broke.
How did the other technologies broke, guys?
Okay.
Wait, all right, let's pick a place.
Let's pick a place for the...
Actually, no, I feel like...
I feel like you dragoons can pick the place for the parkour
tower.
Welcome to the Doki SMP TCG.
Based on...
Uh, an art made by Yifana's resource patch.
You can request cards.
Oh!
Wait, how did the...
How did the technologies break?
Oh, that's cool.
I don't know what it looks like, though, because I don't
have the research pack.
I don't pack five cards.
Why fish no work?
Oh, apparently, yeah, you got, if you're on a server, you
can get research pack and then have, like, TCG with people.
Oh, and you can, you can, oh my god, that's so cool!
Play card games, a card fight.
I just...
Oh my god, wait, what the fuck, that is sick.
You don't have, like, a TCG match here.
I don't have the resource pack.
Maybe next stream.
Next stream, I'll download...
I'll download the resource pack.
And then we can watch... We can watch the TCG fight.
That's so cool.
You guys are so creative.
Not break.
You can place your deck in a lock.
Do not recreate the cards.
Do not exploit the system.
Yeah, next month, let's recreate.
I'll download the research pack and I'll see the TCG stuff.
There's a Doki TCG.
Is it?
Which TCG is this?
That's so cool.
Is it a Doki TCG or is it like a specific TCG?
Okay, who's turning the pages?
Oh, is it original TCG?
Oh, my God.
You guys are insanely creative.
Oh, on this server.
Oh, that's cool.
You should make me, like, the rarest card.
Do I have a card in here?
Yes.
Am I the strongest card?
Answer wisely.
Make me the strongest card.
I want to be...
Who's the strongest?
What the fuck?
This is my server!
Make Mint the weakest card.
And mine, the strongest.
I want to be like the Exodia.
Make me the Exodia.
Make me as the Exodia.
Collect all my parts.
I want to be the Exodia of the TCG.
The Tokyo Exodia.
That's a re-battle.
everything yeah and then batter from tournament play and and
then but only one yeah only one person can have each of
these zodiac right arm of the forbidden bird yeah I'm
single-handed I'm changing the meta I'm changing the meta of
the Stokias and TCG all right Potter green But it's jokie.
Alright.
Show me another new place, admin.
A long neck of the forbidden bird.
What's this?
Whose house is this?
Lit.
What is this?
Oh, is this Valorant?
What is it?
What is this?
Doki.
What game is this?
Oh, I should have read this.
Lit is a PvP game featuring 1v1.
The objective of the game is to light the campfires.
Every four campfires correspond to a point on the
scoreboard.
The first team to score nine points to slow down your point
on you may directly fire them.
Likewise, players can also eat food oh my god wait who knows
how to play this 2v2 let's go
all right 2v2 guys i want to watch 2v2 what's over here hot
dog that's cute hot dogs get your hot dogs here hot dogs get
your hot dogs Oh, there's the beverages.
Alright.
Larry and Shiro Neko.
Versus.
Wait, Ozzy is back.
Is he not restricted anymore?
You don't fucking Ozzy.
Ozzy.
2v2, guys.
2v2.
Only two players on loud.
Aloud on the court.
Ozzy.
Who else?
Who's the second one?
Oh my god, I can't fly.
Only two allowed.
Only two allowed per side.
Figure it out on this side.
This side is all right.
Only two allowed.
People who are not allowed.
Get back up.
Go get out.
Yeah, if there's still more than two in 30 seconds, I'll
kill you.
He'll do it.
He's crazy.
He doesn't care.
Throw me food, please.
Does he deserve food, guys?
All right.
Wait, when I blow this horn, we start.
Let me get the horn real quick.
All right, guys.
When I blow this horn, we start.
Does anyone...
Start!
Is it...
I don't know if they know the rules.
Start.
I don't think they know.
The guys light the fire.
Where's the fire?
Wait, where is the fire?
Wait, is it lit already?
Wait, where is the campfire?
They're supposed to let it.
Do the participants know?
Oh, isn't this?
Oh, they're supposed to like this.
Oh, the other team did not grab the bows.
But, but, oh my God, the other team is winning.
This team doesn't have bows.
this team this team doesn't have bows they don't know what
to do what oh he has the bows he has the bows oh that is
cool wait oh what the fuck wait the point system who's the
builder wait who's the builder for this oh my god that is so
cool Blue team has two points right now.
Wait, red team has zero points.
What's going on?
Three points.
I don't know.
Wait.
Oh, wait.
This team is winning.
This team is winning, I think.
Yeah.
This team is losing.
They're not shooting their shots.
They don't have zero points.
Oh, my God.
Four points.
Wait, this is cool.
Oh my god, wait, shout out to the builder.
Someone say it was Tiny Munchkin.
Shout out to the builder.
This shit is cool.
Oh no, they're coming.
Oh no, third party.
Third party.
Coming from downtown.
How did they have zero points?
Guys, come on.
This is sad now, guys.
Oh my god, there you go.
One point.
I'm pretty sure it's red team that's winning.
Oh, back to zero points.
Wait, one of them died.
They dropped peak and left.
They're like, my job here is done.
Huge shout out.
Huge shout out to them for making this cool-ass game.
if anyone could let him know that we checked it out and we
love this this is sick it's actually really sick job done
our last point you almost got this oh my god they did it yay
congratulations to this team congratulations
Ba-da!
Yeah!
This shit is fun!
That shit game is so creative.
I love it.
Red team wins!
As always.
Turned them to better.
For their punishment!
Wait, wait.
Who are the losers?
I know Dre was one of them.
Who was the other one?
Who is the other one?
Who is the other ones?
Was it Dre and Ozzy?
Dre and Ozzy?
Alright, Admin.
Admin, what's your plan?
What's your punishment?
Oh, you know what?
I'll let you be creative with it.
Alright, we'll let the Admin decide on how How we punish
losers.
What is he gonna do?
I don't even know what he's gonna do.
Curse of vanishing on their armor.
I don't know what that is, but...
Good thing I'm not wearing armor.
right what is that that's so evil what does that do oh it
disappears oh no tools on me either oh no he made sure he
made sure good news for you i'm naked death was more if you
die it disappears curse on bashing on all his items On all
their items.
Can you do that?
Every item has a curse.
Oh, no.
Not easily, but it shall be done.
My word is law.
Wait, what's this?
Bamboo shootout.
What?
Run over congratulations.
You've beaten bamboo shootout.
I did I did Hey guys, I beat bamboo shootout
What is this?
Where does this go?
Maybe great Every time he dies one piece of Germany this
Germany disappeared.
Oh, it's a boat race Oh, I see.
Yeah, I'm definitely going backwards.
Going back up.
Oh, it's like a...
It's a boat race thing.
That's cute.
That's fun.
Ba-da-da-da-da.
Little bamboo city.
I admit.
Show me another fun place.
I'll see another fun place.
Yeah, it's like a little mini game section too.
Which is cool.
I like that.
Oh yeah, I forgot to say.
A little reminder to everybody because there is like less
than four days left.
But the Watson skin, less than four days left.
Acclaim the Watson skin, everybody.
It is free to um it is free by the way that guys the skin
the skin is free you just got complete challenges it takes
like three days like three to four days to claim it so i
just want to remind you guys um yeah uh because after it's
gone it's gone for it you can't claim it anymore so just
want to let you guys know so those who are like oh no i
forgot about it last minute yeah um so just a little
reminder also another reminder another little reminder but
um but the watson plus The Doki Bird Watson plushie is also
ending in four days, everyone.
So I just want to remind you guys that it's just a little,
uh, how fast must, I told me like one, you just have to
complete challenges and there's challenges every day.
Uh, so, um, so it told me like one to two hours per day.
I just play one to two hours per day to unlock it.
Uh, and you can do bot royale.
You can play with against bots if you're like, oh, I don't
want to play against people.
hard to uh claim it uh it's too like the challenge that
you're too hard uh you can do it with bots as well there's
bot royale um and also wild card which is the easiest to get
so yeah so just a reminder everybody whoa wait is this a
cathedral what's this instead of taking make it turn one
random block into bedrock whoa whoa That's so cool.
How long have they been building this?
Oh my god, they've been doing this block by block.
Wait, this place looks insane.
Design started roughly in the...
July?
Oh, construction started.
Okay, I was just like...
Oh!
By the void goons.
Wait, that's so cool!
The void kept...
Holy shit!
This looks amazing, guys.
What the fuck?
There's a lot of hard work being put into it.
They're the same one you made that house into.
No, there's not.
I would never do that.
Wait, is the house still around?
Did they reverse it?
I know there was a pull-up about it.
It's a gift from the heavens.
That is insane.
I gave them the touch of bedrock.
Oh, it's still here.
See, I wanted to show them that the god of Dokilan was real.
There were some non-believers out there.
So I showed them the touch of bedrock.
the touch of bedrock i grace them with my presence it's a
bunker if there's any if anything bad happens they'll have a
bunker to go to you know yeah the toky no it's like midas
touch instead of giving gold i give bedrock it's not a curse
it's a gift They're the most valuable resource.
Oh my god, they caged them.
That is so cool.
What do I just start?
Running!
Oh.
That's right!
What's this?
Why is there a little...
Oh, is this like the watering?
Oh, is that how the water system works now?
Oh,
which way is north?
I don't know which way is north, guys.
Is it this way?
Oh, I think I remember seeing this a while ago.
It's the actual Uma Musume racetrack.
Oh, I found it.
I found it.
Holy shit.
huge is this more accurate is this lower accurate to the
actual racetrack oh man there's a parking lot i like how
there's a park oh wait no that's not oh my god there's like
a little like parking lot and stats to go in too that's
funny where do they start racing
all right we'll do one more build guys we'll look at one
more build admins show me one more build not i went the
wrong way guys
what's this
am i wait why is it all dirt do you guys wait what the fuck
how did you terraform the end did you did you guys terraform
the end why is it all
how the fuck you terraform the end
Oh my god, it's terraformed.
It got terraformed.
I'm back here.
The Mars mission was a success.
There's a hole.
If there's a hole, there's a goal.
It said end drop, so I dropped.
You can't just give me a hole and not go in.
brought life to the endless.
Oh, shit.
What the fuck?
This looks like some Sailor Moon shit right here.
Oh.
That's...
Wait, this is beautiful.
This is actually beautiful.
It's like a little...
Like, uh...
Like a little...
Uh...
What is it called?
Astronomy Tower, please.
That's crazy.
I can't believe you guys terraformed the end.
What the fuck?
There's a fucking random guy on the spot.
Oh my god.
You guys are actual architects.
Wait, it's not even done yet?
It looks so cool already.
I don't even know what else you can add to it.
It sucks.
By one person?
Wait, who was it?
Who made this?
Wait.
But, Saku Saku.
Oh my god.
This is beautiful, Saku.
This is actually beautiful.
Wow.
This is a good build to end on, guys.
This is a good build to end on.
Anyway.
Alright.
That was a lovely tour, everyone.
I haven't checked out the server in a couple of months.
really cool to see like all the stuff you guys have done
since i last looked around chat i always love seeing like
how creative everybody is and like just how fun you guys are
like how much fun you guys are having with the server um i
do okay how about uh new projects guys new project for next
month uh so guys have like some little fun things to do uh
before like the next next stream uh uh so like you guys can
all work together as a community to build something really
fun for everyone um how about i want to try look uh look
into like a parkour tower like a giant parkour challenge
tower where you head up to the top you do a bunch of parkour
challenge to get to the top and i'll check i'll check it out
next month as well and i think it'll be um it doesn't have
to be completed it can be a work in progress and everything
i think it'll be a fun project for everybody too um i think
it's gonna be a nice fun project for everyone to look into
doing uh you should get look at a parkour mod what's the
parkour mod i think my admin can look into it yeah i think
that'd be really sick but yeah dragon you guys are all so
creative and so talented yeah a little round of applause you
guys want to join the server and participate in the server
or like hang out with all the dragons make sure to join the
members uh join members and also click on the link pinned in
the chat uh as all the information instructions on how to
join the uh the
uh you guys can hang out with all the other um dragoons that
are playing and meet new friends meet new goons yeah um i'm
gonna call it here guys i had a lot of fun checking out this
uh wait does the pin not work oh shit i'm sorry guys i
didn't realize the oh shit guys the link has been there for
so long and it never worked what do you mean why did i even
notice that okay okay apparently all right this is this is
the two hours all right here's the actual link by the way i
didn't even i didn't even notice all right here you go i
just now noticed that the link didn't work
if you were a mem uh but the link only works if you're
already a member uh so please feel free to uh to click check
the link out if you want to join uh the survey you want to
check out like hang out with the other dragons here um you
know do some builds and stuff and also the the the parkour
tower yeah i'm super excited i'm super excited to check it
out uh next month too um but anyway uh tomorrow is more
we're gonna try and finish resident evil tomorrow chat we're
gonna try and finish resident evil tomorrow um i don't
really have next week i uh i will for those who didn't check
the earlier stream next week i will be on vacation so uh i
won't uh i won't have a schedule for next week um but i will
still be here for a bit until i leave i won't specify when
i'll be gone on vacation but you when you know you guys will
know uh you'll know when you know um i would say it starts
next week and it's around a week long i'll try to stream at
least i'll try to stream one time when i'm on vacation
because i feel like i'll go through withdrawal if i don't
stream um i'll give you guys like updates on my vacation to
like what i've been doing and everything hey guys i'm gonna
call it here i'm gonna do a little shimmy dance i hope you
guys had fun checking out the server again revisiting the uh
doki smp as always everybody stay hydrated get that blood
flowing and you stay up for me head to bed because you
deserve it i'm gonna head out now guys uh i'll see you guys
tomorrow everybody bye everyone bye guys bye